[Music]
so we're gonna talk about a bit of a
hobby project but if we're pretty broad
this is a talk about many problems if
you will because there are moments when
we know a solution to a problem well
enough that we can compare solutions we
can say this solution to the problem is
better than this solution of the problem
but it might not be the same that we can
say this is the best one that'll ever be
and this is a talk about these sorts of
problems and these problems include
problems like the Traveling Salesman
problem we have to try to figure out a
route that goes by all the cities and
very often if you want to get an optimal
flight schedule in that's also kind of a
big problem
many scheduling problems are problems
like optimal packing problems for also
fall into this category and even things
like getting robots to walk tends to
lovely bit where the robots keep falling
but these are sort of very hard problems
in general you want to do something
about it now the reason that these
problems typically are hard is because
they're easy to score but very hard to
optimize so it's super easy to say hey
let's try out this one solution and
what's the score that belongs to it well
super hard is to say take all the
possible solutions go over all of them
and just pick the best one it's so hard
in fact it I could leave me to find a
set of acronyms to describe a heart
these problems are and they usually
start with the letters N and P this
means that usually instead of worrying
about optimality we try to worry about
finding a good solution in the limit
amount of time so let's say within a day
here's a problem we kind of want to have
a solution that you know performs well
enough so we're in a different country
and to solve these sorts of problems
you'd usually resort to heuristics to
search for like the giant search space
very often they involve creating a set
of possible solutions and typically you
do things to these solutions like random
changes you try to do like a greedy
improvement you try to remove a bad
candidates and you try to generate as
many good candidates but it's always
kind of a wishy-washy mix and match' of
the steps you do like this and all of
these steps can be done in a similar way
but there's something very general going
on here so let's say I'm trying to find
an optimal solution to a Traveling
Salesman problem you kind of see that
depicted here I have a couple of tours
that I start out with and let's say then
I picked the best one and then from the
best one I say just copy that
and then make like weird small changes
then you have a new population this is
one version of such an algorithm but if
you maybe switch it around just a little
bit so you say hey maybe I have a
different way of mutating and I have a
slightly different way of filtering this
is a completely different algorithm in a
way but it's also a very similar
algorithm in a way and there's a may be
a level of abstraction that if we can
maybe make a library for some of the
common steps we might be able to make it
easier to make problems solve solvable
for that are very specific so we started
this library called evil that makes it
easy to define you're an evolution of
heuristic search steps that you can
apply to a population it kind of feels
like working on a data frame in spark
but instead of data we are dealing with
a population of solution candidates will
evolve this population over many
iterations and the goal of this talk is
to demonstrate this library and to show
some things we've learned and some
advice we will now quickly go over some
key parts the API before we're gonna
dive into examples yeah thanks so first
of all I have to say so the idea of this
library is not to make a library that is
extremely quick in solving problems and
I will solve every problem and that
exists in the world the idea is that you
can use in this library you can make a
problems over extremely quickly just try
things out that just easy to put some
basic ideas together and just have a lot
of fun it's probably since its inviting
it's not going to be the fast algorithm
you're right anyway so anything whenever
you do anything with an evolutionary
algorithm the first thing that comes to
mind is that first you have a population
so that's the the most common noun
you'll ever see in an evolutionary
algorithm in evil you will you will
first make a population that consists of
individual individuals and so there's
two ways to do that either you just make
a list of individuals and you put that
and you instantiate a population with
that together with a cost function or
you have the population generate the
individuals using an energy healer story
initialization function
so using this population you can then
use some verbs so first of all probably
the most important step is you're going
to filter and so we haven't called that
filter but we call this survive so you
have part of your population that
survives so first of all under under
water here all the individuals are
evaluated and then some fraction the
most fit fittest candidates survive so
you can either specify a fraction say 10
percent or a fixed absolute number say
10 then after doing that you're probably
going to want and want to make new
solutions new individuals so that's read
so after survive comes breed and for
breed you need a parent picker you need
some function that determines who are
going to be the parents of your new
individual so for example here I have an
example function that's really the
simplest case you can imagine it's pick
random it just takes the whole
population takes one random parent one
parent and then you need a combiner
function which combines all the parents
together into a new individual in this
case that's really simple you take the
parent and you copy it you're done okay
so then we have survived breed and then
of course the last step is mutate in
this case you just take the individual
take the chromosome of the individual
and you mutate it a little bit so maybe
depending on chance maybe I don't know
it's up to you you define this mutate or
function in this case it's flip bits are
given you have a list of bits you can
flip it so these methods of the
population they are chainable a nice
thing about chainable methods is that
you can chain them which means that you
can just in one statement take your
population mutate them then have half of
them survive and then breed new ones so
that your population has the same size
as initially and well of course well
this is just one step in an evolutionary
algorithm you want to probably do this a
hundred times so you can do this a
hundred times
and
[Music]
this one this is five lines and you have
yurov evolutionary algorithm of course
you need to define all the functions
first but we cannot do that for you
because that really depends on the
problem you're solving but there's a
better way so what you can also do is
you can define an evolution instead so
the evolution is an object that sort of
has the same verbs you can call mutate
and survive and breed on it and all it
does it just makes a sort of
prescription of what the algorithm
should do with the population so once
you've defined this evolution you can
apply it to your population by calling
population dot evolve my evolution a
hundred times or the our way around you
can say evolution just evolved this
population and this is really nice if
you have for example two patterns that
you want to follow so first you have one
evolution evolution one and then you
have number two and first you want to do
number one a hundred times and then
number two fifty times and then you can
mix this and match this as much as you
want I think it's time for an example
seems like it so this example is gonna
be a little bit stupid but it's gonna
drive the point home and how you would
use such an algorithm let's say I'm
playing something like blackjack and the
idea is the bank has a couple of cards
and a player has a couple of cards
certain cards are worth a certain amount
of points and the whole goal of the game
is to get as close to 21 as possible if
you ever have a score that's higher than
21 your score gets to zero so it's a bit
of risk in in getting a high score the
decision that you have to make is given
that the cards as your opponent has in
the cars that you have you have to say
do I want to grab another card from the
deck when you do this you are risking
that you're going to get a zero because
you might go over 21 the data structured
everything used to describe this is
basically they say okay so there's a
dictionary that has tuples as keys and
the first index of the tuples going to
say what's the score of my opponent the
second tuples gonna say what's my first
card it's a third tuples gonna say
what's my second card and basically for
every one of those game states that you
could have we have to say are we gonna
draw a new card yes or no so that's the
zero or one you can imagine this is kind
of a long dictionary you have lots of
tuples in it and this algorithm has to
decide hey
what is the optimal strategy that we can
have for this game it's a bit of a silly
example but it has ones and zeroes which
makes kind of nice and again the whole
point of the game is you want to get a
score that's higher than the bank but
you don't want to go over 21 because if
you go over 21
then you're in deep trouble then you get
a score of 0 now the way that you would
implement this is relatively simple so I
have this one function called simulate
where I can say take that actions
dictionary pass that in and then with a
number of simulations that you have
simulate a game outcome against a random
player and we will do this for
population many and many many times I'll
have a population of 40 individuals well
the first step of my evolution is to say
remove everyone except for the five best
ones then pick two in this case pick
three random characters I have a
combiner function that just says for
every single action that is possible
just pick the one that the most parents
have that's sort of the most popular
thing to do and then mutate it maybe
flip a few bits at random and do this
over and over and over and over again
then you learn something this thing will
run and what you can then do is this you
can sort of log the population objecting
and get a nice visualization out what
you see on the left-hand side here is
the population fitness over time and
what you see on the right hand side is
the data structure for the chromosomes
so every key is mapped to something on
the x-axis and if it's a 1 or 0 it's
either yellow or black and you can see
over time what the best chromosome is
doing and what you can see here is we're
not learning anything currently my
genetic algorithm is failing is not
picking up any patterns and the reason
is I'm not simulating enough if you do
the same thing but you do it for 10000
simulations then BOOM suddenly it learns
something and I see that my algorithm is
performing better over time the reason
here of course is if the chroma saw of
all the actions you can have is with
let's say there's 4,000 actions you
could take if you're only simulating a
thousand of those and obviously not
sampling the entire choice space small
lesson we learned this is a example of
something you could do with a genetic
algorithm but the thing I want to stress
at this stage is it's not just a genetic
algorithm that you can implement with
this library this way we just give you a
couple of base verbs for you to play
with
but if you want you can also do
simulated annealing or pheromone methods
seemingly the leading annealing is kind
of like saying we're gonna mutate the
population constantly and as you can see
here so some of the members of the
population get better green some of them
get worse red and in the beginning of
the iterations we we're fine if some of
the population members get worse however
as we sample more and more a variable
that we call temperature gets higher and
then we get more picky which means that
if someone gets worse
we don't sample the worst person we just
say you're gonna say exactly the same as
you are this is a variant of a heuristic
but you can imagine that might work and
this is something as well implement you
can also do something like a pheromone
method basically generate a new
population every single time but the way
that you generate a new population is
dependent on the best ones of the
current population basically here for
example you can say hey sort my entire
population take the better ones learn
that get some sort of probability
distribution from those and then sample
from the prob'ly distribution to make a
new population and repeat this over and
over again now because it's the end of
the day I won't stress you with the
actual code that does this but the gist
of it will look something like this you
just say hey there's something called a
temperature that I can keep track of and
at every single iteration the
temperature changes and my mutation
function will use that temperature to
mutate my population and the same thing
you can do with the pheromones as well
the idea here is we're gonna give you a
small little framework that shows a
direct line of thought that will give
structure to the way you're building
your ear estates this is one example but
we have our library has a bit more
features if you want to do something in
the order of learning how to play
certain board games or card games so
here comes another example which is
completely useless who of you does not
know the game of rock-paper-scissors
good so well then you know that unless
you can predict your opponent's moves
there is definitely no winning strategy
I mean it's completely random so the
goal of this example is not to make a
good bot I mean there's plenty of
websites where you can actually play
against other people's BOTS I'm not
really interested in that I'm just
going to have a little bit of fun here
but first you have to note that when we
do this we have a problem because we
cannot define an evaluation function of
a single chromosome because a chromosome
is going to like make a decision either
rock or paper or scissors but that
doesn't translate to a score we cannot
calculate a score of that we need to
have it compete against another player
and only then can it win or can it lose
that means so a chromosome on itself
does not have a score but it only has
this score compared to another
chromosome and for this we have a
solution so instead of the normal
population object you use a contest
population and this just takes two more
arguments and one is the contests per
round so basically that means the number
of contests every individual is going to
play every time it is evaluated and a
number of individuals per contest so for
rock-paper-scissors clearly that is two
but of course it could be on red and
then the main difference here lies in
how the evaluation function works so the
evaluation function here is going to
look like this it's not going to accept
a single chromosome it's going to accept
two chromosomes two players and but both
of these players are going to make a
choice and then we're going to return
one score but two scores so if they make
the same choice obviously is it dies or
both of them get 0 and otherwise it
completely depends on what they chose
and one of them gets +1 and the other
one gets -1 and then over all these
iterations all the all the gormers ohm's
play random games against other
chromosomes and we just sum the scores
and those the ones that won the most
games are the best ones so for this we
still need to define a chromosome in
this case it's not just a list or
something I made a class it's a
rock-paper-scissors player and I made
this fun really really stupid the idea
here is that you can see so when I
initialize it it sets a preference so
player has a preference for one of the
three options and whenever you play so
depending on the arbitrariness
it's either likely to either pick a
random choice or take its preference so
it's just a little more likely up to
very much more likely to take the
preference over a random of course
that's a really stupid thing to do if
you're really playing this against
someone because they'll find out if you
have a preference well again we need an
evolution it just looks the same like
always and then well turns the question
which is best is it work is it paper
where is it scissors what do you think
this is actually going to converge well
let's see so here we go with the default
settings you see over the iterations I
did 200 there were iterations and then
you see the Preferences of the most of
the population and you can see that this
varies this fluctuates a bit it does not
converge
it just keeps fluctuating but it's each
if the Preferences keeps about like one
third of the population so now it's not
converging but we can play around with
this a bit more for example if we reduce
the arbitrariness so by default it was
one half if we set it to one quarter
which means that at least in
three-quarters of the times the players
are going to choose their preference you
see some interesting pattern emerge it
looks like it's oscillating we can
reduce the arbitrator's and even more to
10% or to zero and then we just see
oscillations so what's happening here
well of course whether your fitness here
depends on the rest of the population if
you choose rock and all the others have
scissors then of course you're going to
win so then the next round it's better
to have rock and a number of rocks is
going to grow and then it's better to be
favored if we also if so if we reduce we
reduce the fraction of
individuals that survive is round that
we can even change the frequency of
these oscillations and this just what
every round it's completely that the
odds are completely turned and it's so
the rules of the game have changed
entirely like I said it's useless but I
think it's fun so we started making this
because we partially we had a small joke
so this year at PI data Amsterdam will
hear did a talk on risk analysis to get
all the financial clerks into the room
but basically it was a bot that played
the board game risk we thought it was
pretty funny too the the idea behind
this basically came from we want to have
bots that play board games and card
games on our behalf and that's kind of
where this came from but we ended up
making some that might be a little bit
more general making all this stuff that
we did learn a couple of things if
you're building an algorithm like if you
do with the meta eristic whatever you do
even if you use our library try to solve
them pen and paper first make sure you
understand the problem very well for all
the crossover functions that you may
have for all the mutate functions that
you make you have a function that can
generate an individual then you also
have a function that can take an
individual and mutate it so you can
write tests for these functions as well
test everything and then passes through
understand your problem much better than
your solution please otherwise you get
weird things that happen and try to
never ever generate a candidate that is
surely suboptimal sometimes you have
people that say all we need more
randomness we need more noise we need to
generate plenty of people to make sure
that we don't get stuck that's all very
much true but if you're sampling
individuals that you know are gonna be
bad you're gonna be in that territory
and mainly try to think when you've
exhausted type of parameters because
something else might be going wrong
having said this in general though our
library once again is meant to make it
more fun to play with heuristics and
they give structures of these heuristics
it helps you to structure your wristt
exert but it may also be the case that
many aristocrats are suboptimal there
are specialized solvers for certain
problems out there and that we will
never beat so if you know sy PI there's
a couple of optimization tools there
google has open source the operational
research tools so if you have traveling
salesman problems google our tools
actually has algorithms for this so you
can just use from the box that will
always outperform anything
here having said that I do want to talk
a bit about some of the features that we
have because we are writing this in
Python 3 we can make use of some dynamic
typing so in the function method sorting
method I should say we can actually say
what sort of type of object we expect
that goes into the method but also the
type of object that goes out and you can
do this with a string even so you can
see an evolution object goes into the
evolution thing and what goes out of
this function is a population object the
nice thing about this is that if your
method chaining in a tool like PyCharm
you can autocomplete indefinitely so you
can make a chain that's like 10 long and
we will always be able to generate these
out of complete messages for you in
pycharm do you put a notebook kind of
does this but not so much but definitely
if you're making this in PyCharm you're
making a command line app that optimizes
this this is a bliss to work with we are
going to be adding a couple of extra
features to this we love playing with
this but as you can already download and
play with this but it's a couple of
things that are still missing if you run
a genetic algorithm or any year istic
ever you do want to keep track of the
best solution you've ever had and we
want to solve that problem by offering a
logging framework as well it also makes
visualization of the algorithm very easy
the idea basically is you just said
where is the log file and if that's ever
set we will make sure everything's
logged appropriately we should also be
able to paralyze some parts as I said
before some of these evaluations can be
expensive if I have to simulate a game
10,000 times because otherwise I won't
converge then that does mean that if I
do a certain mutate and the mutate
doesn't change the chromosome I don't
want to reevaluate it twice we have a
mechanic for that but also when we're
evaluating the scores we can do that in
parallel because basically these are
things that you can just apply function
to so that something we're going to add
we're also going to add a couple of nice
helper functions so how to select
parents how to maybe memorize some
things we're gonna add support for that
and we are likely to be adding support
for island populations we just had a
Content population which is a certain
type of population that makes it useful
to simulate certain types of problems
island populations or populations where
you can basically say hey there's a
population now split up into three
separate groups and everything that's
going to be happening afterwards it's
going to happen to every one of these
groups independently so if you do a
breed or filter it happens per Island
not on the entire population and we're
also in the market for an informative
logo
the features humor so if you know anyone
who does illustration well we're happy
to learn more about that now because
we're getting at the end of the
conference though we should talk about
the one last problem that we think is
the funniest thing at this talk yes one
last problem I realized that I am right
right now I'm in between you and your
beer so well let's talk about that so
this this is my first time in more so
same for Vincent
so of course we need to like explore the
city so what could we do tonight how do
we optimize this well of course we need
to visit some pubs which ones well you
can just look that up best 10 bars in
morsel looks fine right okay so
scrolling through this page then we have
to decide which pub to visit or better
in what order do we visit all these pubs
well okay so let's get to it how do we
solve this for starters we need to
navigate from pub to pub so we need some
information from Google Maps so import
Google Maps initialize the client put in
the addresses of course we need to start
at the conference right here so that's
the Copernicus Science Centre Coco gets
that I don't need to type in an address
and of course I like to end up at my
hotel tonight because otherwise I have
to sleep in some bar now okay let's get
first let's get the locations of these
bars so just call the API geo code
address and it would and then we can
look up the locations which include
latitude and longitude we can also ask
for walking directions so we know
exactly what the distance is between all
of these pubs and since it's only ten or
twelve things that we can just easily
ask all the the walking times or walking
distances between all of the
combinations so using these latitude and
longitudes we can visualize it these are
all the pubs including our hotel and the
conference location
that we want to visit okay good now
again we have to define a chromosome
which in this case is just the list of
the pubs in the order excluding the
conference in the hotel of course
because these are fixed at the ends a
combiner just put two lists together
we're using some crossover method I'm
not going to go into that and some
mutation as in just flip to the location
of two pubs in the list and then again
we need to define an evolution which is
just the same as always
then we need a cost function right and
the cost function is just easy it's the
distance but there there's something in
here as you visit more pubs I'm pretty
sure you're going to walk more slowly
and since these are 10 pubs I'm thinking
I think this this is a significant
effect so we've included this with this
drunk factor that increases with the
number of pubs visited I hope it's
accurate we still have to do some field
testing okay so then the results we
start at the conference and then well
I'm sorry I can't pronounce that
I think but well here's the list so you
know where to go take a picture but I'm
afraid you'll have to substitute your
own hotel again your mileage may vary
so again visualizing this this is what
the solution looks like it looks like
it's found the optimal solution right
okay
so but let's visualize it a bit more I
think this is more intuitive so we start
here at the at the Science Center we
cross the river there's one pub there
and then we just go through all the old
town and then at the end a red bar that
red pin that's our hotel so ready to go
but unfortunately so when I was actually
doing this I hadn't realised there would
be an after party so I guess we'll have
to do this some other time
thanks for listening the code
of course the code of evil can be found
on get up let's do one question I
realize these questions between this and
beer right do you already branded us as
map reproduce reproduce right so no I
think the first thing we're gonna add is
the just standard Python multi-core and
keep it at that for a bit this will
never be the fastest way to do genetic
algorithms it just unlikely if you
really want to do it fast maybe try it
in Scala it's not too hard to do this
with the RTD API I guess but we're not
no ok one more high the oxidation
observation that you guys saw it is
something to were expecting or something
that took you guys by surprise the first
time I saw it I it took me a little bit
by surprise and then of course I went
looking for to get it like well first
first why but of course well the moment
you see it it's sort of obvious because
you can see that one population just
eats the other up but then yeah then I
just went looking for it how can i
amplify this and how does to tweak this
to make it strong strong as oscillation
as possible one small thing to add with
this we also have another colleague who
did this for monopoly and there you kind
of see the exact same thing a certain
strategies beat other strategies which
get beaten by another strategy which
again gets beaten by the former strategy
so this is something especially in board
games and card games you see all the
time beer o´clock beer question ok
there's one more ok I don't believe you
it's actually more of a comment I just
wanted to say that you can't spell
Traveling Salesman without ales man
that's like a joke I should have
in the slides it is thanks yeah we're
gonna totally steal that
okay I've feed this is a good point to
finish today
you